et
bonjour chers internautes
bienvenue sur diagana delà de son
bonjour et loire bonjour bertrand
bonjour à tous alors nous allons
reprendre pour la rentrée un nouveau
cycle de leçon avec donc et loire lange
qui est l'un des plus jeunes grands
maîtres français et qui va nous aider à
comprendre toutes les phases de la
partie
eloi je crois tu a réfléchi sur une
nouvelle méthode pédagogique sur un
nouveau plan pédagogique pour la rentrée
peux tu nous en parler
oui alors c'est à dire que les échecs
c'est avant tout un jeu c'est à dire que
pour s'entraîner pour travailler il faut
avoir des objectifs précis à comprendre
c'est beaucoup plus facile en tout cas
comme méthode de travail donc ici nous
allons étudier sa part ten avec un
premier thème donc plus ou moins
intéressants plus ou moins efficaces
c'est la taxe sur le roi qui permet de
gagner énormément de partis de façon
assez simple
donc ça ça va être divisé en trois
parties attaque sur le roi au centre
attaque avec les rock du même côté
attaque avec les rois opposé évidemment
puisque quand on veut attaquer l'ennemi
faut pas non plus affaiblir son propre
rôle donc ça donne des configurations
différentes
je crois que tu as pensé aussi à
maintenant donner à nos à nos
internautes
un répertoire d'ouvertures alors ça va
se passer comment alors voilà c'est là
que justement intervient sept cette
méthode qui est donc très en fait très
basique et très qui est utilisable
directement donc ce qui est donc à mon
avis plus pédagogique et bien simplement
on va vous apprendre à jouer d ouverture
avec les pièces blanches c'est à dire
voilà vous allez jouer au 4 et ensuite
on étudiera donc successivement toutes
les défenses possible des noirs et on
vous donnera des idées dans chacun
chacune des configurations possibles que
je peux choisir votre adversaire
bon un petit peu de finale 1 pour la
pauvre technique et alors les émissions
ça se passera comme ans et les oies et
moi même allons commenter une partie
modèle sur un thème le thème de la taxe
sur le roi le thème de la structure de
pions et après eloi nous donnera ses
lumières en essayant à l'aune de ce
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui de savoir
comment on joue cette position c'est à
dire qu'on étudiera principalement des
partis classiques et ensuite on verra
une des possibilités un peu plus moderne
un peu plus récente qui donne en général
lieu des milieux de jeu plus compliqué
en tout cas la base ça sera très très
classique et très très éducatif
alors aujourd'hui la tarte à la crème
des parties d'échecs ce que tout le
monde doit connaître c'est l'équivalent
de borg mcenroe au tennis c'est la
partie morphy compte le duc de brunswick
et le conti soir alors deux mots sur
cette partie hyper célèbre de mou sur
cette partie père célèbre bien alors
historiquement je ne suis pas très
féru 6 rue oui tout à fait simplement
donc ce que je dirais c'est que cette
partie a été jouée je crois au théâtre
pendant la représentation du barbier de
sibérie donc film assez long on filme
barbier de sibérie bat bienne série le
barbier de séville c'est à ce n'est pas
grave donc voilà j'ai effectivement pour
les faits historiques c'est mieux que ce
soit bertrand qui vous explique en tout
cas la partie techniquement et très
intéressante est effectivement
polymorphie était un traître un
excellent joueur d'attac extrêmement
connus qui avaient donc la faculté de
gagner énormément de parties très vite
il a très très vite cerné en fait avant
tout le monde tous les grands principes
du développement de l' attaque et la
disposition des pièces donc c'est une
partie modèle en fait tout simplement de
l' attaque contre un joueur qui n'a pas
respecté les grands principes de alors
je crois que les vaut mieux y aller donc
premier coup de mort fille ckoi et loi
alors on va passer en petit nous avons
là c'est le coup eux deux quatre
effectivement puisque à l'époque où
cette partie était jouée c'était quand
même le coup numéro un
pourquoi puisque on le rappelle encore
une fois ça permet très vite de sortir
le fou et la dame
donc c'est un coût qui permet de sortir
deux pièces directement on va vers le
petit rock rapide
c'est ce qu'on va voir tout de suite aux
4,5 alors les aristocrates eux hésitent
à des six morphine fait faut que je le
fasse
si mon fils est faut que je le fasse
tout à fait eu 4 5
l'asymétrie pour l'instant rien de bien
particulier deux cavaliers f3 rappel
puisque c'est la rentrée pour repartir
sur des bonnes bases au soudan les
ouvertures des chèques
il faut sortir ces pièces de préférence
les cavaliers d'abord et toujours en
direction du centre alors effectivement
qu'il y avait trois atouts du coup
parfait puisque on a sorti une pièce on
crée une menace directe
on attaque le pion aux 5 et en plus le
cavalier contrôle également la classe
des 4 donc on contrôle de cazaux centre
c'est un coup parfait tout simplement
d'accord alors qu'est ce que peuvent
faire les caisses que vont faire plutôt
les noirs les aristocrates rv à les
appeler comme ça hein qu'est ce qu'ils
font elle aurait dû la route 17 des six
qui déjà est réputé quand même
légèrement inférieure puisque on préfère
dans cette position on va y revenir
sortir une pièce on préfère jouer calais
b 8 ans et 6 qui est un coût plus
positionnelle tout simplement puisque
en même temps enfin en réponse à kiev 3
eh bien on fait le même effet avec ilife
6 qui contrôlera les cases des 4 et
australe ça c'est comme moderne assez le
couvert mais des six effectivement est
très jouable sa part la menace de façon
directe le pion aux cinq était en prise
maintenant il est défendu un petit peu
d'histoire
c'est le coût 10 de la défense philidor
suzy d'or qui était un grand musicien
est un grand joueur d'échecs du de la
fin du xviiie siècle
voilà sans aucun doute donc françois
andré dany cohen exact à vif ils y qui a
inventé cette défense des quatre très
logique
alors pourquoi déjà les blancs ont une
position très saine tout simplement
parce que hein
ils ont pris le centre ils ont mis un
duo pion au centre c'est ce qu'on a
toujours envie de faire dans les
ouvertures aux 4 et d4 c'est parfait 2
ils ont sorti une pièce de plus que les
noirs mi-longs et cavalières f3 donc
c'est une pièce qui a été développé les
noirs n'ont pour l'instant pas sorti et
3 effectivement c'est l'avantagé d'avoir
sorti les deux pions c'est que
maintenant toutes les pièces sont prêtes
à sortir le phocéen
le fouet fin donc bien entendu le
cavalier peut aller en c3 et ensuite on
peu rauque et donc pour l'instant la
position des blancs est très très
prometteuse ils ont à jouer les
meilleurs coups ils ont joué les
meilleures ici fou g4 a alors ça mérite
un commentaire ce coût est réputée comme
étant en principe on va dire une faute
tout simplement parce que il faut sortir
les cavaliers avant les fous voilà ce
que je dirais pour commencer ça c'est ce
que disait tu arraches 1 le grand
championnat allemand qui était une sorte
de paix des grands pédagogues du gel
échec mais pourquoi alors pourquoi
simplement parce que en fait le cavalier
à une classe naturelle
c'est sûr on voit bien que le cas belge
et un va aller en f3 on n'a pas envie de
le mettre sur les autres cases d'un
coeur qui sont moins fortes
le câble ibm lui valaient en c3 c'est
très logique c'est ça qui est naturel
par contre le fou c'est beaucoup plus
difficile à dire le fou ou prenons par
exemple fouet st on sait pas s'il va les
en a eu deux ans et quatre pour attaquer
c'est sur cette diagonale la voir même
en b 5
le fou deux à trois casses possible donc
la logique est de rester souple le plus
longtemps possible pour pouvoir sortir
le fou où on a envie de le mettre donc
la raison c'est vraiment une raisons
pragmatiques les cavaliers si possible
avant les fous mais qu'il est impossible
en les autres inconvénients de ce
courroux g4
inconvénient assez important cette fois
c'est que ça expose le fou le fou a
priori est venu ici il va probablement
s'échanger contre un cavalier et ça ça
donnerait la paire de fou
oui mais alors moi je vais faire un
contradicteur souvent on dit aux
débutants et parcs aux débutants même
aux joueurs plus forts essayer de clouer
les pièces adverse
c'est vrai alors c'est peut-être la
suite de la partie qui va nous donner la
réponse
voilà tout à fait c'est ce qu'on voit
c'est ce qu'on va voir tout de suite ici
paul murphy se débarrasse du clonage
d'une façon assez tranquille il joue
tout pronostic alors alors là surtout on
prend pions
c'est une variante on va alors la
regarder voilà ici il y aurait d'un
programme échec au roi ouais on reprend
dame
maintenant on s'est déclaré d'accord
hélas le cavaliere 3 se retrouve
complètement libres d'aller manger le
pion à ya plus de clouage puisqu'il n'y
a plus de courage
les noirs sont des rockets c'est un
cauchemar ici c'est tout à fait fini
nous apprécions pronostics pas d'autre
choix pour les noirs que de jouer fou
prend cagliari 3 1 c'est ce qu'on
appelle un coup intermédiaire un coin tu
arriverais pas l'éviter d'accord
exactement
on reprend de la dame et maintenant la
pression prendre 5 bilan sur cette
position
les blancs ont pris la paire de fou
c'est à dire qu'ils ont deux fous contre
un seul pour les noix rencontre ce week
end pour un grand maître ça c'est
quelque chose aussi l est les débutants
et même plus que des débutants se disent
j'essaye de garder mes cavaliers parce
que c'est compliqué c'est vrai dans les
sens mais le joueur fort il faudra faire
les fous ils préfèrent le fou parce que
le fou à une plus longue portée d'action
quand il y en a deux ça va très vite et
ça va sur toutes les cases c'est très
important
m'enfin là c'est pas le thème de la
graphie du jour pour l'instant le thème
c'est plutôt le développeur
développement puisque le développement
est une chose très importante est ici
évidemment polymorphe ils ne s'en
privent pas il joue fous ces quatre
coups qui est un énorme avantage c'est
que ça sort une pièce le fouet fin ce
s'est développée et ça crée une menace
ça c'est important parce que ça en
créant une menace on va empêcher
l'adversaire de se développer
donc ça c'est les bases de la taxe sur
le roi comme comment est-ce qu'on va
développer une attaque sur le roi au
centre on va sortir toutes nos pièces en
gagnant du temps de préférence et en
empêchant le roi noir de roque est
d'accord donc ici ça commence par tous
et théâtre donc là c'est une menace
terrible et fall apparaît
as primaires tout à fait non une sorte
de maths du berger c'est même tout à
fait le match et on est d'accord
alors qu'est ce qu'il faut faire alors
plutôt qu'est-ce qu'on fait les
aristocrates leduc et le compte 1
pendant ce barbier de séville ou bah oui
pour eux ils imitent le barbier de
séville leur regard de plus à ce moment
là et c'est plutôt la partie qui les
intéressent mais ils n'ont pas envie de
se faire mater leurs preuves de ses
affirmations convient de se faire mater
il faut donc paré le mat
il faut trouver une défense il ya des
possibilités de défendre avec la dame
on peut également pousser le pion wife
le mettre en oeuvre six alors ça c'est
pas du tout recommandé dans cette
position puisqu'après le faiblir et la
position du roi donc ils trouvent un
coup très logique le coup que tout le
monde a envie de jouer dans cette
position avec les doigts
c'est le coût cavaliers ans m6 pourquoi
c'est logique et bienvenu atangana tu
t'arrêtes pas de nougat qu'il faut se
développer là on se développe et on perd
le match et ça sort une pièce mais ça
ressemble au coup parfait morphy a vu
que loin donc ici il ne faut pas laisser
souffler les noirs parce que si les
noirs sortent leurs pièces et bien la
position va être plus ou moins
équilibrés c'est à dire qu'on sera
obligé de jouer sur le long terme
arrêtez c'est une c'est une lutte au
début pour le développement c'est celui
qui sort le plus vite ces pièces qui
peut prendre l'aventage faux pas il faut
javaux vraiment mettre ces pièces en jeu
là il faut pas le laisser souffler il
faut pas laisser les noirs sortir leurs
pièces comme ils ont envie de le faire
c'est à dire que si on land si on le
sait jouer beaucoup de suite y jouait
pour l'enfant des 6es petit rock
il se retrouverait alors à l'abri donc
ici morphy la taxe sur le droit au
centre c'est ça s'est très vite ces
dames b3 on rejoue de faux avec la même
pièce mais c'est pas grave puisque on
crée une menace sur le turf 7 est une
autre menace sur le pion b cette double
menace double menace donc un coût qui a
l'air très bien qui a l'air très fort
ici le coup joué et dames 7 pour
protéger surtout le mat pour protéger le
pion à vii sachant que pour répondre à
ta question et la femme n'y avait pas de
coups qui protégeait les deux choses
c'était donc c'était déjà foutu mais
alors donc ici
voilà ici position très difficile après
davos atteint en fin d'année 7 a été
joué effectivement que fait murphy dans
cette position il peut prendre l'option
b sat
ouais mais il ne le fait pas puisque il
préfère en fait les maths et son
adversaire ça c'est une danse et une
décision un peu en donne aussi une
décision de morphée où c'est vraiment le
meilleur coût alors question de point de
vue
disons que les haut niveau ou jouez pas
le mort fille à l'époque les deux coups
auraient gagné on peut dire ça
maintenant effectivement mort fille a
une réputation à tenir
c'est un joueur très violent un joueur
qui aime gagner rapidement qu'ils aiment
les cahots rapide ray et donc
effectivement et choisi non pas d'aller
chercher les options qui auraient pu y
jouer mais qui a mené à une finale avec
quelqu un de plus qui aurait été longue
et laborieuse à transformer il préfère
sortir une pièce encore une fois à la
caisse et 3 développe une pièce très
logique des fonds de curieux 4
perspectives d'avenir sur la case des 5
et menacent cette fois sérieusement mais
de prendre l'option b 7 puisque les
noirs n'ont plus la ressource stanley 4
échecs ses 6 les noirs sont ne peuvent
plus sortir de pièces pour défendre
l'option b 7 ils sont obligés donc de
jouer encore un coup de pions ce qui
n'est pas une bonne chose alors là
qu'est ce qu'on voit dans cette position
tout est prêt pour la taxe sur le roi
tout est prêt pour quoi et bien parce
que les noirs n'ont pas encore sorti le
film donc ne sont pas prêts de rock est
puissant par pas de sortir parce que son
papa de sentir faudrait bouger la dame
ya pion à vii qui est en prise si on a
envie de jouer qui avait 17
malheureusement le pion bessette va être
prise encore une fois donc ici les noirs
ont des gros problèmes de développement
donc comment faire pour réaliser une une
attaque très violente et virulentes sur
leur beurre noir il faut continuer le
développement des pièces il faut faire
entrer les tours en action parce qu'on a
le temps de le faire ici
donc maintenant morphy souffle et joue
ou g5 clouage développement prépare le
grand roque et l'invasion la colonne des
on voit qu'après grand roc la tour va
venir sur les cases d un donc contrôler
une multitude de cases que la position
noir est très très difficile
autant dire qu'elle est pratiquement
perdre déjà donc le coup logique 17 b 5
on se débarrasse de ce qu a enlevé cette
bague en plus en même temps on va
chasser le fou
deux cases blanches effectivement le fou
normalement de est amené à reculer et à
ce moment là on pourra jouer cavalier
b17 est sorti en au ps mais ici morphine
n'est pas d'accord l'amphi n'est pas
d'accord simplement parce qu'il ne veut
pas jouer une position tranquille il a
un avantage de développement qui est
énorme et donc ça doit se valoriser il
faut absolument en profiter et il en
profite très bien puisque ici ils
sacrifient ils sacrifient à ça c'est non
si je résume un peu ta pensée le
développement pour la taxe sur le roi
c'est encore l'été un moment donné les
blancs plus de développement dans qu'ils
peuvent se permettre d'être violent et
là le sacrifice mais les sacrifices
apparaît simple pour un grand maître ou
peut-être pas forcément pour un grand
maître mais pour un joueur aguerri mais
pour quelqu'un qui est en progression et
est ce que c'est comment ça se passe
dans un dans le cerveau d'un d'un fort
joueurs pour arriver à cette décision
alors puisque ce que je suis tenté de
dire c'est que donc voilà on est dans
cette position là notre fou se
retrouvent attaque et on fait un peu une
sorte de méthode d'exception c'est une
méthode russe enfin méthode en tout cas
qui a été bien formulée par les russes
c'est qu'on regarde les coups qu'on a à
jouer et si nous plaisent pas on
commence à chercher des coups qu'on n'a
pas envie de jouer des coups qu'on
penserait pas à jouer habituellement ses
notes la méthode d'exception la méthode
d'exception c'est à dire que là les
coups normaux n'ont pas l'air bon donc
il faut trouver un coup d'exception tout
simplement il faut trouver un sacrifice
puisque la position a l'air vraiment
excellente
on a sorti quatre pièces contre 2 les
noirs sont complètement embouteillée on
voit qu'ils sont pas prêts de route et
ils ont la dame recettes pour l'instant
donc en fait on a une position qui
al'air écrasante
en revanche si on commence à replier nos
pièces c'est une mauvaise opération
mauvaise opération puisque les noirs
vont sortir les leurres finalement et on
n'aura plus que l' avantage minimum de
la paire de fou ce qui est pas
satisfaisant donc il faut trouver un
coup exceptionnel puisque la position le
demande on voit ici qu'on a une position
vraiment qu'il ya beaucoup de
perspectives qui a l'air extrêmement
forte
il faut donc trouver un cookie un cours
à un chaos en fait il faut trouver de
cowes mais ça c'est une sorte
d'intuition qui savait qu'il va se
développer au fur et à mesure que vous
allez jouer des parties d'attac
vous allez commencer à sentir un petit
peu que là il doit y avoir quelque chose
et donc commencer à envisager
naturellement les coups comme cavalier
préemption des cinq qui sont des
combinaisons
je dirais pas spécialement difficile une
fois qu'on a l'habitude de les faire tu
reprends cavaliers oui maintenant il ya
une suite découvre ce qu'on appelle un
force et c'est à dire qu'il faut les
prendre mais il faut prendre un sari
cheikh fou prend échec donc là
effectivement on n'a pas envie de bouger
droit arrêté puisque sinon si on joue
roi des mythes qui a une possibilité
les blancs vont jouer gros rock avec
échec développant encore des quais à ses
attaquants droit cavale et b17
polymorphie joubran rock et là laurent
là on voit une position assez
sympathique avec une sorte de double
clouage double clouage puisque les deux
cavaliers sont cloués le fourbe et saint
cloud le cavalier 17
le fou j'ai cinq tubes gaby à 6 et si on
a créé une menace directe puisque le
cavalier m6 et cloud et donc on menace
de prendre le cahier 17 ne se jouer
simplement tout reprend 17 qui gagne le
cavalier 17 puisqu'après cavaliers prend
la dame noire serait emprise et donc pas
de solution le seul coût pour les noix
retour des 8es la polymorphie réfléchit
encore
il se dit voilà dans cette position je
ne vois pas comment je gagne directement
à priori je peux jouer tout prix même si
ça marche pas ainsi c'est ce coup là on
va quand même le pointer point m6 les
noirs reprend scène pour reprendre
simplement dû plonger il se passe pas
grand chose prendre le quai 17 n'apporte
pas grand chose puisque après fou prend
il ya tout reprend mais cependant ma
position une fois de plus à l'air
vraiment très forte
il faut trouver quelque chose de
d'important quelque chose de très
intéressant je vais donc essayer de
mettre ma pièce qui ne jouent pas en
action et le plus vite possible le plus
vite possible à ses cercles on pense
rapidement à une manoeuvre comme ça mais
ça c'est long c'est trivial
ces dons effectivement ça va peut-être
gagner aussi mais c'est très long et
c'est pas très joli
alors là il trouve quelque chose de
merveilleux mais est ce que tu veux
montrer là c'est qu'il faut penser
finalement au développement de la
tourache il faut pouvoir là alors envoie
ça c'est un bon principe quelle pièce ne
participe à tourbillon 17 morts alors là
les noirs n'ont pas le choix on n'a pas
le choix puisque s'ils prennent de la
dame
ils vont perdre la dame par le fou
dessin et et s'ils prennent du cavalier
ils perdent la dame parle 500 tout ça
c'est relativement simple
le calcul est simple oui pour prend 17
la tour d un temps d 1 ça y est on a mis
à tour en jeu maintenant les noirs non
plus tous ces désespérés il faut se
déclarait absolument
il joue des mots si c' est l' une des
combinaisons les plus connus de
l'histoire d'un échec puisque c'est elle
a fait l'objet d'une multitude de balles
puis ça dans le parisien ça dans tous
les bouquins dont gouailleur des échecs
et puis je fais sur diagonale aussi et
dont il prétend donc voilà ici les
blancs jouent et gagnent il ya beaucoup
de solutions il y en a une qui est
radical il s'agit donc de fou prend 17
le cavalier bien prendre dame b 8
sacrifice de dames sacrifice de dames
donc on est obligé de prendre la dame
ici qu'à 6 passes on n'a plus que deux
pièces en jeu puisqu'on a sacrifié
toutes les autres mais ça suffit pour
mater puisqu'on joue tout d un an des
huit échecs et mat
analysons de maths quand même puisque
c'est important la tour fait cher au roi
la tour est défendue par la foulée 5
c'est un match extraordinaire
le roi ne peut pas sortir sur la case au
set puisqu'elle est contrôlé par le
fonds g5 et ne peut pas les en dés 7
puisque c'est contrôlé par la tour
seimat
là y'a rien c'est pour ça que mort fut
pendant des années était adulé par tous
les joueurs d'échecs morphine est un
super joueur vraiment excellent cette
partie est un est un modèle
donc on récapitule ski tout ce qui s'est
passé dans cette partie rapidement en
premier lieu on a commencé à prendre un
avantage n'avance de développement on a
sorti deux pièces contre zéro pour les
noirs ensuite on a continué le
harcèlement
sur les cases blanches en attaquant le
turf set en faisant des double menace
est toujours en développant des pièces
en gagnant du temps une fois qu'on est
sorti beaucoup de pièces on a été obligé
de sacrifier on a été amené à sacrifier
mais c'était le moment et ensuite il y
avait plus qu'une pièce qui était pas
dans l'action une fois qu'on la ramène
c'est fini c'est très violent
alors moi je vais jouer une petite
partie contre toi pour voir si je peux
trois places et sa chance à le ce fameux
coup alors nous allons réussir a aussi
finalement essayons ces pratiques tout
ça c'est tout ce qu'on va vous montrer
essayé après de le mettre en pratique
tout simplement humain alors supposons
que j'ai joués fou j'ai 4 au troisième
coup alors donc les faux que j'échange
j'échange qui en compte cinq
je suis là je n'ai pas le choix pas le
choix je joue pour un f3 d'en prendre un
pion prend hélas je joue j'essaie le
coup du berger le couffo c4 chaleur
développe ici d'une façon moderne je
dirais d'une façon actuelle de voir les
choses on ne jouerait pas cavani m6
puisque la réplique de morphine mp3 est
trop forte
il faut trouver une autre solution une
solution qui n'en bouteille pas les
pièces il faut jouer un coup un peu
atypique il faudrait jouer je pense des
m17 en tout cas c'est ce que je jouerai
non c'est la vitesse qui est qu'est-ce
qui simplement pour pour les gens qui
regardent la leçon pourquoi alors
d'abord effectivement le fait de
connaître un peu c'est parti là ça
permet d'éviter de refaire la même faute
donc je ne s'agit pas de les connaître
par coeur mais de connaître les idées
mais pourquoi tu va choisir des m17
l'homme 17 alors parce qu'il faut parler
maths je n'ai pas envie d'avancer mon
option de frs importance que c'est vrai
qu'il faut jamais oublier cherepanov la
première des menaces je n'ai pas envie
de jouer c'est tf6 et je n'ai pas envie
non plus de mettre la dame sur la case
au set où elle boucherait la sortie
probable du fouet fuite la sortie à
venir du fouet fuite cavalière si ce
n'est pas bon f si ce n'est pas bon il
faut parler de maths
donc il n'y a plus qu'un seul coup
possible ces dames 17 mais au fond tout
ça comme si on réussit on regarde les
principes du développement il ya plus
que ça donc dès le 17 donc la fao blanc
bon alors alors quelle coupe je peux
dire moi je vais essayer de me
développer petit rock petit rock c'est
très logique effectivement on va le
jouer tout de suite et sur petit rock je
pense
qu'on aurait envie de jouer beaucoup
comme soudée 6 pour la stabiliser la
position là malgré tout tu es solide
oui c'est toi sache sachant ça tu vas
quand même même si tu sais que tu es
plus fort pour ton adversaire au début
tu es solide et tu fais attention tu le
respectes quoi quoi qu'il arrive à bas
ici c'est pas le bien et le mal
maintenant que ce n'est pas il faut pas
non plus flambé puisque c'est ce qui
amène au au drame je joue food et six
dans cette position donc on peut encore
continuer quelques coups mais le but des
noirs ici effectivement c'est de
stabiliser la position avant tout sort
dé 1 par exemple tour d un donc clouage
de fous ici j'ai trouvé un plan
intéressant c'est que j'ai envie de
sortir mon cavalier du g8
si je le mets en f6 j'ai très peur d'un
coup comme fou g5 qui chassera le
cavalier dont j'ai envie de le mettre en
hausse est donc je vais aller jouer qui
a blessé six ont fait diversion sur la
thèse des cartes donc là maintenant
c'est moins simple c'est moins simple on
pourrait continuer éventuellement par
ses 3 et là je crois que le bon coup ce
serait calé dès 8 s'est implanté en tout
cas c'est un plan général pour les noirs
suivi de cavaliers cette suite petit
rock on stabilise la position et ensuite
on commence à réfléchir
bon bah écoutez donc à enchaîner pour
l'attack au centre la rapidité du
développement le rock on le redira je
crois 150 fois on va revenir dans les
autres le sont sur d'autres méthodes d'
attaque mais je crois que cette partie
là regarder l'art regardez la elle est
très importante
alors il ya une petite combinaison pour
finir un petit et grands pouvaient tirer
de la philly d'or parce que ça c'est
bien aussi elle donc l'entraînement
c'est ce que vous disais tout à l'heure
et loi c'est à dire que petit à petit à
force de vous entraîner à des petites
combinaisons comme ça de la main la main
fini par travailler autant que la tête
ou les deux en même temps et donc on a à
vous soumettre une petite combinaison
issus de la filière alors et loire pour
la fille dont on traite plus ici se fout
g4 n'est pas le conte moderne on joue
principalement dans cette position soit
cavalière 6 soit cavaliers ont 17 donc
nouvelles possibilités qui a 17 les
blancs évidemment sondes sont très
chauds toujours poussé ces quatre c'est
un bon coup dans cette position de toute
façon puisqu'on voit que les cases
blanches côté noir ont été légèrement
affaibli donc ici on chauffe ou c4 et
maintenant la faute des noirs le fou
bien en deux sets
c'est une faute c'est une faute je pense
que le bon coup c'est calais gf si ça
doit être le coup moderne où ces six ces
six en tout cas est une valeur sûre ici
il ya une combinaison alors cela
effectivement c'est pas facile à sortir
il faut quand même avoir une idée un
petit peu original le roi est au centre
les cases blanches sont un peu affaibli
on n'en dit pas plus sain dit pas plus
puis on prend de 5.5 il a aidé mme
effectivement rien de toute façon pour
vous aider on va finir là-dessus c'est
que les combinaisons ça passe souvent
par l'ouverture de la position oui
l'ouverture des lignes effectivement qui
qui donne des perspectives nouvelles
si on prend 1,5 deux possibilités pour
les noirs on va les résumer rapidement
soit cavaliers prend soin qu on prend
les deux possibilités principale selon m
on aura perdu un pion donc sur cavaliers
prend que se passe-t-il ici cavaliers
prend lyon prend hélas le thème de la
tacc double on en a déjà parlé dans
diagonale la leçon la dame vient au h5 a
taillé et le pion à vii et le pion aux
cinq gagne un pion net avantage pour les
blancs puisque là on ne peut pas parler
de menace à la fois
autre possibilité les noirs reprennent
du plomb et là c'est beaucoup plus grave
c'est une faute très grave puisqu'on va
saigner une attaque violente au roi noir
en profitant de la de l'affaiblissement
des cases blanches avec le ku'damm des
cinq attaques le pion à vii et comme le
fou s'est vite a été bouché et
embouteillées ne peut pas venir à l'aide
du roi noir et c'est donc ici terminée
vous pouvez vérifier tranquillement chez
vous il n'y a pas de défense contre
12.197 c'est un gain rapide un chaos
rapide dans l'ouverture
voilà alors voilà je les aime finalement
le match mais ça c'est ma du berger sa
cellule berges à améliorer mais donc ça
arrive le mât du maire j'ai simplement
et faut le préparer en se développant
ses salles à la philosophie de tout ça
le mode du berger c'est ça en fait
disons que l'idée de plus tôt de la taxe
sur le roi au centre c'est qu'il faut
essayer de gagner du temps l'empêcher de
rock et ça c'est très important si ne
n'est plus au centre gagner du temps
nous sortir toutes nos pièces et envoyer
tous à l'attack donc fait des parties
d'attac je vous conseille jouer ou
quatre sorties toutes vos pièces et fait
des belles parties d'attac mai
il vous reste ne nous reste plus qu'à
vous souhaiter une bonne semaine un bon
jeu merci et loire et puis la semaine
prochaine c'est la semaine prochaine
s'ils l'attaquent sur les rois du même
côté du même côté du même bonne semaine